hello everyone thank you for being here
in this talk
uh today I'm going to talk about
um
how we can use uh specific techniques of
machine learning such as time series for
the energy sector I am Hosanna and I
work at hack on time series specifically
focusing on problems in the energy
sector
so I like to think that the problem of
oh and the energy sector is uh very
closely related to AI for social impact
because uh when we deal with a Time
series in the energy sector we are
basically dealing with the topic uh
number seven of the sustainable
development goals that is to create more
affordable and sustainable energy for
all and we know that we are living in a
moment of a climate crisis uh in the
history of mankind so to say and this of
course brings a lot of
um
a negative consequences to the like the
the whole Humanity especially in
countries uh toward like a close to the
south of the world but uh overall every
country is affected and um one of the
ways that we can tackle the climate
crisis is through our consumption of
energy
so we can uh bring more sustainable
energy solutions to the world and we can
use for sure the power of technology and
the power of AI specifically to make
this process much faster
so
when we talk about the energy transition
we have oh I'm afraid that this is not
presenting as it should but uh I can
tell you more or less what is in there
so we have
um several aspects that we can deal when
we are talking about the energy
transition maybe the most common uh
known is uh the uh adherence to
renewable energies but of course we can
also consider that we can make uh the
use of energy more efficient for example
the user we have in our daily lives so
we don't uh waste energy uh we can also
consider the topic of electrification so
there are currently in the world many
countries that are many areas in the
world that don't really have any access
to energy and of course for those
regions most probably the transition
will to renewable energies will go
directly without having this fossil fuel
and resources related to it or at least
like as a major source of energy
and of course we are also talking about
[Music]
um
different sources of fuel that not
necessarily come from a highly CO2
emission emitting sources so for example
we talk about hydrogen we talk about
many other uh energy sources and as I
mentioned before one of the motivations
of using AI or using technology in
general is to make this transition uh
faster and more efficient
so we can all uh do our best to reduce
our CO2 emissions and limit the climate
change
um aspects that we are seeing uh the
consequences that we are seeing right
now in the world
so
when we talk about AI in the energy
sector of course we have to consider
there are several factors we uh like the
the different uh sectors or Industries
in the world are usually divided into
business and the government so to say
that is considered the second sector and
there's the third sector that is like a
more related to organizations or
University Research and so on so we need
of course like the engagement of all
those three sectors to actually make an
effective change in the world well when
it comes to the energy transition
and of course in Industry uh we talk
about a lot research and development and
like the creation of new technologies
building new tools that can make this
transition faster but of course there is
a lot of a lot to do also with
government in terms of policies and
implementation of those policies and
also in terms of the third sector by
seeing how different communities engage
in like how the the society itself can
also be part of this energy transition
and um
when you talk about all those changes
and all those sectors and so on of
course like uh specifically about
technology we can look into
uh the the topic of uh clean energy
adoption as being the most maybe as I
mentioned before like the most uh common
um and to do that like the way that we
can use Technologies mostly through
forecasting of a supply or some or like
how much energy is produced and also
demand of energy so we can uh kind of
prepare the logistics of this energy
distribution uh in a way that makes more
sense
but we can also think about
installations of facilities and also
like a analytics of how energy is being
used so we can uh create systems of
recommendation that can make it more
efficient and so on and of course for
all those uh Technologies and all those
use cases there are many
um different AI or data science uh
methods that we can use here I'm
mentioning just a couple of them
and now what I'm going to show you is a
couple of examples of how we can use
those
um
methods but of course I will be focusing
a bit more on time series because this
is like uh the the goal of this uh this
presentation
so uh when you talk about Time series
uh time series is basically a data set
that contains timestamp data and
timestamp to here like uh here we are
showing we are seeing an example of
timestamps that is basically an index
for your data that comes in terms of a
date but of course this can also be in
terms of time as well there can be like
our intervals of I don't know 15 minutes
you're checking the data or can be here
is in terms of days but you can also
have in terms of weeks in terms of years
depends a lot on the problem that you're
using but basically it's a problem that
you are looking to that doesn't have a
static Behavior so every variable they
were looking into for example here
you're talking about temperature we're
talking about humidity we have a
different like something that uh some
variables that not only depend on each
other but they also depend on time so
you have in a way another dimension to
consider and there is Dynamics So like
um things change over time
and um this can bring a lot of
consequences for example you can have
periodicity so you can have things that
change but they have somehow some
Behavior behind and that's actually what
we try to leverage with machine learning
techniques or overall time series
analysis techniques to just understand
this Behavior behind those variables
um so when you talk about time series in
the energy sector uh specifically like
when we talk about
um energy uh production from renewable
sources you can consider that renewable
sources depend on uh variables that uh
depending on the weather so for example
it can be rainfall for hydro energy you
can build can be wind and temperature
for uh wind energy can be solar
radiation
um cloud coverage and so on for solar
energy and all those variables
dependent of time of course like this is
something that is not very easy to
predict but they are all variables that
change over time they have seasonalities
depending on the season that you are in
the year and depending on where you are
in the world
and uh and this is one aspect but then
also in terms of energies not only
renewable sources but energies in
general for example the consumption we
can think of the demand of the
population that will be affected by
different uh kinds of uh variables such
as social economics or location and so
on and also of course when we talk about
uh facilities so for example for uh
whatever
oh energy source that we have it it
comes from a facility uh be it a power
plant period a turbine and so on and the
monitoring of those facilities is also
important to understand if things are
functioning properly and so on
so apologies
um an example of
um a use of NLP in terms of like
understanding text analysis over time is
uh for example the use of for the policy
and decision making
and uh we can think for example here of
what happened this beginning of this
year uh with the
Ukraine crisis and uh and the war that
started and consequently the energy
crisis that started uh here in Europe
and worldwide in a way and here's an
example of the simply Google thread uh
like a search that we sorry Google
Trends searches that we have
for Germany
and then we can see that at the
beginning of the year that we started to
have a lot of searches about the the
wars about the Russian Ukrainian war and
at the same time the increase of the
searches for solar energy in the country
uh
was was quite high and stayed uh steady
and that basically tells us that uh the
population of Germany especially for
this for this search
um is becoming more aware and more
interested in solar energy and this is
something that we can see in the long
run in terms of policy and decision
making in industry and government and so
on so this is something that that gives
us some direction of uh how people are
thinking and it is quite an interesting
uh like a topic for the people
especially more like for for uh policy
and so on and this is a good use of
natural language processing because you
have to see what kind of like words
you're kind of like a sometimes not only
words but like a groups of words or
sentences and surrender being searched
or combined them but this aspect of time
is quite important because then you can
see that you can look for correlations
between events
so another example is the monitoring of
Dems so this is something that can be
done via satellite imagery and of course
also like a the monitoring of facilities
this is what we are showing here under
uh
left ring the hand side of the image
and here we are looking into uh them so
for example for producing Hydro energy
and looking into satellite images uh can
give you lots of information from a
specific region like a specialty like it
was very like large regions and here is
an example of looking to the
displacement of um
of Earth or of of the soil throughout
like this is in
um I think it's a centimeter or
donometers but it's just like to have a
notion if there is for example a very
like a fast displacement that could
indicate for example that the dam is
about to break and then this of course
means that we have to evacuate the
region and uh try our best to save
people
um this is of course like kind of
monitoring of facilities like in a large
scale but you can also look into in the
right hand side here in the image like
uh for example the power quality
um so for example you can analyze
power quality both in power plants
ordering households and you can just
Monitor and understand how the if like
the electricity that people are
receiving uh is is going is being
received like uh consistently or if
there is something that looks a bit uh
strange and so on some anomalies that
you can find and of course this uh gives
us an ocean if there is some problems in
the system and so on
um moving on to another example or we
have uh the more like in the economics
area we have the energy prices formation
this is something that uh for the ones
who are in the field of energy is like
basically what we call the Merit order
so
the prices of energy will be dependent
on the the most expensive source of
energy that we have available
and
um
here's an example if you have a low
amount of Renewables here as an example
for Brazil so that's why we are talking
about water but uh in general if you
have a lower uh amounts of renewable
energies this will imply that the higher
that you need more for example gas here
in this example uh and then gas is more
expensive and if you have more
Renewables on the other hand this is
like what you see here on the right hand
side that means that
um we have more uh cheaper resources
available and then we will need less to
use less of the other resources and this
is what we are trying to transition to
like a scenario where we depend less on
gas that we have more renewable energies
in this uh hopefully will decrease the
prices of energy but uh to understand
the formation of prices it's also
important to consider that we need to
know the sources and uh when we talk
about specifically about renewable
energies this is something that depends
on weather and so on that's why time
series analysis for this specific kind
of problem is so important because we
can understand in terms of prices but
for example we can also look into the we
need to know how much of energy is
produced and how much of energy is
consumed so we can finally come to this
model of prices and when we talk about
energy production here's an example for
wind energy
and for wind energy we can consider it
as I mentioned before that we have
climate variables we also have to
consider the facilities because for
example if you have a wind turbine that
can only produce certain amount of
energy doesn't matter if there is more a
wind you cannot produce more than that
you can also have to consider that there
will be firm estimating this energy you
have to consider there will be
correlations to other variables so other
environmental variables for example in
this case of wind also temperature so we
can look into wind speeds but we have to
also consider for example temperature as
well and of course of the composition of
the the signals or the time series that
you are looking to so for example if you
want to look into the temperature and
wind Temp and wind speeds we have to
consider that there might be some Trends
because of
um season
there might be there might be some
changes because of climate change for
example there might be like some
increase or decrease of those variables
as well
and uh here I'm just mentioning that you
can use techniques such as machine
learning and data analysis to understand
a bit better how you can predict those
energy Productions
um here is an example of wind but of
course you can apply this for solar or
you can apply it for hydro and uh also
to fossil fuel related variables as well
and in terms of energy consumption is
more or less the same uh however uh when
we talk about energy consumption is not
something that depends purely on nature
so it's not something like how much the
wind blows or something like that but we
also have to consider that there will be
a kind of human or societal aspects for
example we can have peak times that we
know that people are going to work or
that people are at home uh also like uh
climate and weather as well but more
like in the sense that if it's warmer
people especially in the south of the
world people use more AC in the north of
the world if it's too cold people use
more heating so understanding those
different
um infrastructure so to say is also
important and of course like a regions
in the world that have more uh
economical resources tend to use more
energy than regions that are not that
are more like maybe Rural and so on and
also variables such as uh calendar for
example holidays and so on will affect
the demand of energy because for example
on holidays people might be traveling
and then they will not be using
necessarily the energy at home but maybe
they will be using more energy in in
like a hotel structure
infrastructures and so on
okay so moving on
um we can also have the energy
consumption uh understanding energy
consumption for example through
clustering techniques that is an example
of unsupervised learning technique
uh to understand a little bit of what
what I was saying before for example you
can have profiles you can have just like
a bunch of Time series from a specific
region and you can look into
similarities among those profiles and
understand that maybe some here in the
example
um
one area has like a a higher consumption
sorry one group has a higher consumption
throughout the day this might be related
more like a two the green one for
example here might be more related to
um commercial buildings where people are
working throughout the day then you can
have something like the blue curve that
is more like when people are there's a
peak in the morning and then a peek at
night but throughout the day is a bit
less and this consumption can be for
example to I don't know fridge or
something that is turned on the whole
time but it's way less than throughout
the the morning and evenings and in the
red curve you have for example holidays
when people are also traveling they are
not at home but there are things that
are still turned on
and these are examples of um uh ways
that we can look into uh applications of
machine learning and specifically time
series in the energy sector but uh let's
maybe have a look a bit deeper into what
is behind those techniques that are
mentioned in there in terms of use cases
so for pre-processing and data analysis
and Ada mean here means exploratory data
analysis we can look into for example
imputation so for example if we have
missing values and you're dealing with
time series uh it's important for those
specific cases uh that you need to
understand for example if you are
measuring if you're monitoring something
in terms of like a what resolution is
it's yearly monthly 15 minutes and so on
uh also if you have some specific dates
as I mentioned before for example if you
have holidays or if you have
peak times or off-peak times and
um this this the nature of your problem
will Define what is the best way to to
deal with those missing values so often
you will use um
um averages so you can just take the
mean value of some time interval but of
course you can just take the the missing
the like you can just mimic the same
value that you saw before or after
um in the in your timestamps around this
missing value you can also use the mean
or the maximum of some interval and you
can also consider interpolation but
basically for example if you have a
missing value for
something that has a an hour resolution
in February or something it doesn't make
sense to use for example the the the
average amount of consumption
throughout the whole year because this
will not be very consistent with the
month of February so maybe it makes more
sense to look into which day of the week
we were looking or if this was a weekday
or a weekend or a holiday so like
understanding this nuances from time
series is important to determine what is
the the imputation method that you're
using that's why I mentioned like
resolution and specific dates because
then you might use an average or
something or the minimum on Max but then
you have to know which interval makes
sense for this uh specific interval that
you're looking that is missing data
so you can also look into a Time series
decomposition as I mentioned before
time series not only have like a pattern
but they can have like a specific
patterns of trends for example of
increasing or decreasing and they can
also have seasonality their seasonality
might be related to specific like uh
climate Seasons as we talk but can be
some other kind of seasonality
uh here is an example on the top right
of for example the rainfall in Singapore
uh because of climate change we are
seeing a trend of increasing the amount
of
like the uh the um so to say like the
average is increasing over time and this
is a consequence of the climate crisis
but you can also see that there is a
seasonality that there are Peaks and
valleys here that is related to of
course like the seasons that are seasons
that are more rainy than others and so
on so this is like uh you see some uh
regularity uh that comes more or less in
the same frequency and also some trend
of increasing or decreasing
uh also related to time series uh
decomposition uh are components that you
have or you can also have cycles that is
a bit similar to seasonality but not
quite this is very common in economics
for example there are like a Cycles you
need to have something
some behavior that repeats itself but
not necessarily in the same interval of
time so it doesn't have necessarily the
same frequency and this can be related
for example to uh different uh social
aspects for example here it's like if
you're looking to stocks and then you
have a different crisis that happen or
different societal events that happen
that we will influence of course the
stocks and then it will change the
behavior
so here we have more or less same
behavior but that is affected
and this of course will not have the
same frequency because those events that
do not depend on something that will be
always frequent uh in the same interval
and of course like we have also noise
that is basically uh we can never
reproduce a Time series completely so um
you can uh the trend a Time series you
can remove seasonality you can even make
some effort to remove Cycles where you
still have some noise that comes of
course from the fact that usually time
series are not completely stationary so
you can try to de-trend and do all those
techniques uh so we can for example use
um forecasting techniques but you have
to consider that this is going to be a
bit affected by this factor that is not
most of the time series that you have
out there are not stationary
okay moving on uh we can also look into
anomalies and anomalies especially in
the energy sector come
often from uh weather or whether or
slash climate in Social economics uh so
for weather for example we can think
again about the climate crisis and here
it's not been possible to see very well
but like for example you can have
extreme weather events or special events
that are happening because of of the
climate crisis in this effect the the
weather conditions for example here's an
image of the El Nino that makes the
temperature of Singapore also increase
to more extremes than we were used to
and this is something that you have to
consider when you're building your
models that anomalies might not only be
just errors but actually something that
has a physical reason behind uh at the
same way we also have social economics
that can be for example uh the pandemic
or the war it's something that will
change the behavior of energy
consumption here is an example of energy
consumption
um
throughout the pandemic so we see a lot
of residential increase of the
residential
um
energy consumption and a decrease uh
from commercial buildings that's
something that is still going on
and
here uh I'll leave for now the
stationarity and out of correlation is
something that already mentioned we can
also look into feature engineering that
is considering different variables such
as lag and um
like like variables and the moving
averages there are basically to
understand that the former uh former
steps on the time series will influence
much more than or like a previous like
something that happens happened much
earlier so uh this is like we can create
new variables that will be relevant for
this um analysis so that we can create
new features that will be important for
our models and uh in terms of a Time
series forecasting we can look into the
interval of predictions for example we
can have uh predictions that come in
long term and predictions that come in
short term
and uh in terms of forecasting models
you can have uh different kinds of
models there will be
um important for time series uh
forecasting for example you can have
um models that already receive a raw
time series such as a recurrent neural
networks or Facebook profit or Auto
regressive models
and uh also other like a traditional
machine learning models that we'll need
to have those feature engineering
techniques considered uh over there
and in terms of evaluation it's
important to consider that uh when we're
dealing with time series
uh it's not only important to look into
the metric in terms of like how precise
your prediction is but also like we are
trying to predict a behavior so we not
necessarily only want to look into a
specific um
um like a very precise predictions but
also in the the shape of your curve if
that makes sense if it's increasing or
decreasing and so on and uh with that
I'll just uh thank you all and say that
the energy transition is here to stay
and we will uh need to use a lot of
technology and I think time series is a
very good use of this so thank you very
much and stay in touch
would you like to take this one question
down there uh from Juan do you know of
any approach of AI or machine learning
to predict the El Nino weather event
um I am actually not very sure because I
think that those uh specific methods
that are like a four
um meteorological there are some uses of
AI but the as far as I know uh using
like physical models are still more
precise because then you are really
considering the the real physics behind
and the methods and so on